Well, it's good to be home,
but we can't get too comfortable
because we're taking our little news show on the road
later this week.
We're Drew's newsing from Philly.
Hey, Philly. We're coming.
Uh-huh, yeah.
Maybe some cheese steaks.
Please, please.
And then we're also coming
from our nation's capital, Washington, DC.
It's so epic.
Yeah, we have a news desk.
We will travel.
So if you want us to come to your city,
hit us up on social media.
Maybe you'll see us right there.
That's right.
Have desk, will travel.
Hit us up.
Please welcome us, or request us in your city.
We will show up.
I can't wait for Philly and DC.
I know. I know.
Well, there's no better way to kick off this news
than with one of the biggest superstars
in digital comedy right now.
He's got millions of followers on Instagram
who are absolutely hooked on his incredible characters.
He recently took his talents to Washington as well.
Here's a look at Benito Skinner.
Hey, everyone.
Usually I start off with a big coffee.
Sorry, they're like really strict in here.
Hey Jenny, I booked you a nail appointment, love.
Yeah, I didn't tell you to do that.
It's called initiative. (laughs)
Hi, White House, this is Cooper.
I don't think so.
Oh, doesn't matter.
Oh, thank you, honey,
These suck.
Sofia on XCX, put on chem trails.
Anastasia, get out here for your swim lesson, honey.
(audience cheers)
Please welcome back to the show,
Benito Skinner aka Benny Drama.
(audience cheers)
Literally, like, I'm in heaven.
Oh my God, you're the biggest deal in the world.
I'm so-
Oh, stop.
Oh, I can't. I will never.
And by the way, I posted your video
that you do Danielle from "Ever After," the film I was in.
And your Danielle is everything.
That movie is my favorite movie ever.
The wings?
No, it was my fantasy.
Gimme one line of Danielle.
Oh my God.
Well, I think I'd have to just like, breathe.
Just breathe.
(audience cheers)
(Drew and Ross laugh)
That was my fantasy come to life.
Yeah, it was an honor.
Alright, well, let's jump into the news.
Hey, oh, we gotta talk about this.
You know, we're back in the city and all summer long,
the talk of the town has been "Sex and the City."
Are you ready?
SJP, Cynthia Nixon, and Kristin Davis,
they're shooting the HBO Max spinoff, "And Just Like That,"
which is what it's called.
And Vanity Fair reports,
you can get all the leaked info you need
on Instagram and online.
There have been tons of photos of the ladies on set
revealing new cast members like Nicole Ari Parker,
and shots of Carrie in bed with Mr. Big.
And okay, I feel torn about this
because I am looking forward to this
more than anything I've ever looked forward to
in my entire life.
And I feel like about these leaks,
they feel like dessert for me, you know?
Like I devour it and then I just feel bad about my choices
because I wanna wait.
I wanna see the whole thing when it comes out.
Thoughts?
No, so okay, I also devour it.
It's kind of like if music leaks and I'm like,
I can't touch that.
Like the artists wouldn't want me to,
and then I'm like, play it again.
All right, well, your story next, Benny.
Oh my God. My turn.
Next, we're gonna talk about
the latest dating term on this one.
Wait, how do you guys do this?
This is so stressful.
I feel like I'm in like fifth grade,
I have to read in front of the class.
By the way, if someone told me
like just come up with a character out of thin air,
I would feel the same way.
So, just go.
Okay, my turn.
Next we're gonna talk about the latest
dating term on the block.
Why am I reading this like that?
Roaching.
(audience laughs)
(Drew and Ross laugh)
'Cause this is your news character.
In Style reports, Roaching refers to
when the person you're dating
is sleeping with a ton of other people,
and not telling you about it.
That's also called being a horrible person.
That's a really simple thing you can say.
If you know of even just one person,
he's hooking up with other than you, get out the Raid.
Spray it.
(Drew and Ross laugh)
Ross, Drew, have you ever been roached?
Oh, I mean, I just assumed.
Here's the deal.
I think unless you're exclusive,
you're not exclusive, you know?
So you should just assume you getting roached,
and ironically, it doesn't bug me.
Pun intended?
Yes, totally intended.
I just think until you have that convo of like,
you and me and no one else, right?
You just should short of just accept the facts.
'Cause they getting it.
But I do like when new vernacular
comes into our zeitgeist,
and we can now say, oh, she's roaching, he's a roach.
I think that's fun.
It think it's fun too.
And honestly, like, it has the right tenor,
like the tone for what you're doing.
You are roaching.
Yeah, like you're vile.
You're a roach.
But we have something else to do though.
I'm very excited because
we built a brand new digital studio.
It's upstairs.
It is stunning.
It is gorgeous.
It's fun.
It's giving me like MTV in the 80s vibes.
And we are so lucky because Benny,
you are gonna be our very first.
You're gonna christen it and we are gonna do it together.
So thank you for doing the inaugural digital piece with us.
Of course. I love that.
(audience cheers loudly)
Oh my God.
Yay!
I need another character, and we're going for it.
(upbeat bright music)